This lesson's major focus is on key concepts in data modeling.
We'll be talking about some new terms like fact tables,
dimension tables and keys.
But before we get into all of this,
I'm sure some of you are wondering,
why are we tackling data modeling before we
even start loading datasets or creating our queries.
If you're, give yourself a gold star,
It's an excellent question.
We named this lesson key concepts and data modeling,
but we could have just as easily called it prep work for Power Query.
When we're looking at our pipeline with the queries feeding into tables,
it would be easy to conclude that we should start by building out
the queries that we will pull into the source data and feed it into the tables.
You might think that these queries are simply the source data as is,
and that this will define what will be made available in the data model.
That might be true in terms of how the pipeline runs.
But in terms of how you think about and plan your pipeline,
it's really the other way around.
You should first think about what the data model and report needs to look like,
and only then write the queries that pull
the data you need and support that foundational build.
As a budding data model there,
I want you to get into the habit of beginning with an end in mind.
I recommend you sketch out your data model using the raw materials you
have each time you're preparing to develop a report,
even before you open the Power BI software.
If you don't do this,
you risk a very time-consuming cycle of guessing,
checking, and correcting your queries.
While you can't loop back to change queries
whenever you run into issues in the data model,
and this is certainly something you will still run into time to time.
Even if your initial design was perfect,
such as when data changes or reports requirements change,
you'll still find this process a lot faster and much less
confusing if this rework is the exception rather than the rule.
With that potential source of confusion out of the way,
let's look at what we'll cover in this lesson.
In this lesson, we'll delve into the core components of data model structure.
First, we'll talk about the wrong way to model your data with unit tables.
This is where we mash everything together and create one giant,
very inefficient data table.
Then we'll talk about the main components of a data model.
In particular, fact tables,
which are tables that store our aggregatable or additive data, dimension tables,
which store our descriptive data, keys,
which provide values that we can use to create relationships between our tables.
We'll see that one of the key takeaways in this lesson is
that by separating our data into fact tables and dimension tables,
and then using relationships to connect them.
We can create much more efficient data models.
Planning the tables and relationships in your model is critical.
We'll look at how to make a simple sketch of
a data model before we start building anything.
We'll consider from a high level how we can restructure the source data.
Logically shifting or transforming datasets to
meet the needs of a data model and the resulting report.
Some examples of this might include merging data from one source to another,
or reworking how columns and rows are
represented in your query to meet the desired end result.
Finally, we'll check out how we can use the VertiPaq analyzer and
DAX Studio to make some of these key best practices more concrete.
In general, the stage we're focusing on here is one part getting your head on
straight and one part planning how you will communicate to the Power Query software,
what it is you want to accomplish.
In this lesson, we'll learn how to do both of those things,
so that when we go to create our pipeline,
we know exactly what we're building.